[Music]  located in central London is a public  park that remains hidden to even the  locals this great big story is made  possible by Marriott Bonnefoy Rewards  reimagined  the medieval-style Church of sin Dunstan  in the East was built in around 1100 and  has had a long 900 year old history in  1666 it was rebuilt after being damaged  in the Great Fire of London then during  World War two a direct hit during the  London Blitz  destroyed a majority of the structure  leaving behind only the north and south  walls and steeple instead of rebuilding  once again the City of London decided to  turn the remains of some Dunstan in the  east into the public garden which is  accessible today if you know where to  look  tucked away from the main road the  garden is situated between the Tower of  London and London Bridge the green Ivy  covered walls trees and flowers offer an  enchanting escape from the city and  serve as a reminder of London's history